alright so I'm a nature the guys both
three what's what's going on in book
three well think about what happened in
book once too so book one we got
introduced to everybody there's three
guys involved Cicero just kind of hangs
back he doesn't actually contribute to
the discussion he's only there at the
very beginning on the very end and what
one was mainly this this epicurean guy
presenting his position their gods the
way they understand it they don't do
much of anything that's why they're so
happy because they teach themselves are
being affected by it by human beings for
errors or anything like that and what's
your kind of got got to speak in the end
of that and he really tore into the
other curie by the way Cicero was not a
big fan of the Epicureans he thought
that among the various schools of
philosophy the up hearings were kind of
intellectual lightweights but you know
they're there they're important school
so that's why he discusses them and as a
representative then we get to the big
heavy hitter this the stoic and in book
two that's what we talked about last
time reitställe consumption of God's a
little bit different than you know
Jewish Christian Muslims conception of
God because their God really is the
world it's what we call pantheism
meaning God is the fee is impart of it
God is everything God is the totality
things and then they had a whole bunch
of of you know God and God bless or
something like that we could call them
God God's light that did certain things
in the universe and they actually
identified these with stars and their
view of the ancient Greek Roman god cuz
these are mostly allegories can stories
there really is no Zeus it really is no
Neptune that's just a way of talking
about the CD you know rationality and
rebating the sea the Stoics are very I'm
very much about reason being involved in
everything so if you were a stoic it was
it was kind of
holding point of view because you can
say well you know God actually takes
care of everything God knows best God is
rational more rational than we are and
so everything that happens happens for a
purpose you guys have all heard the
stuff like this right when do people
usually say that sort of things usually
when things are going well what does it
have bad things happen to you and people
are like no it's hard to go through but
there's there's some hidden reason for
this and sometimes that's been so like
an often times but a lot of people you
know actually haven't been of you and
when it comes to their own stuff and it
helps them get through and the Stoics
were you know pretty good at this
stoicism was very appealing to military
people both in ancient times and even in
the present when we have a stoic revival
and people like Nancy Sherman can go and
give talks at west point about stoic
warriors so it was a way of you don't
sort of getting by and it appealed to
people who kind of lost faith in the the
traditional Greek and Roman religion who
said yeah I don't probably buy the stuff
though these gods and you know Zeus
impregnating all these women and making
more gods and you're getting mad at them
and trying to kill some of them and you
know it goes on and on and on right
fighting the Trojan War because you know
there was a decision having to be made
about an apple because no that's at
origin story right how the Trojan War
got started now listen this is kind of a
good example actually the Trojan War
ties in with Rome too because because
the Rome is according to its you know
from legendary history started by a
Trojan who happens to get out of Troy
with
his father and his infant son who also
goes to carthage beloved by a woman
their queen and then takes off leaving
her house only heartbroken Trojan War
get started because the goddess eros
eros means discord or hatred or like
think about the kind of person has
always got to stir things up right
that's the goddess Eris there's some
sort of feast and she's not invited so
she says I'm going to fix that and she
gets herself a golden apple beautiful
apple and she inscribes out to the fair
and then she like plops in the midst and
three goddesses lay claim to Hera queen
of the gods Athena goddess of wisdom and
you can even say just war surround this
ryan and Aphrodite goddess of love lost
you know bodily designer that's where
they're all goddesses so they all you
know a lot pull and they're all pretty
that's kind of tough to judge between
them and each one says that she's the
prettiest so the way it sort of like
Snow White and three Evil Queen's isn't
it and this is what we got to judge so
let's get some guy and they pick this
guy Paris who happens to be a prince of
Troy and what do people do and they want
to get the judge on their side sleep
well right Brandon yeah these are
goddesses they're not they're not
actually going to sleep with this dish
mop Paris but you know they one will
arrange for him to sleep with somebody
so here are offers him she's a queen of
the conoces like you know in charge of
everything in a certain respect she says
I'll make it to this this you know great
ruler you can be emperor of everything
and thena I can't remember exactly what
she promised
something like prowess and war you know
strategy that sort of thing and
Aphrodite says well you get to sleep
with somebody I'll give you the most
beautiful woman there is now just what
happens the most beautiful woman he
happens to be married already and
there's a whole backstory to that while
these guys and who liked her took a vow
that if anybody would would screw things
up between her and her husband they
don't take revenge together that's why
the Greeks go off to Troy yeah Helen of
Troy well how I'm originally of Sparta
because she's married to Menelaus and
then she becomes Helen of Troy when
she's the prize for parents because he
says yeah I'll take them I'll take the
lady instead of power or wisdom or
something like that and then you get the
Trojan horse now all this is legend
stuff right and give the Trojan War the
way it's described the gods actually
like take sides you know you can figure
if if Aphrodite is on the side of the
Trojans these other two they're going to
be outside of the groups right yeah and
they actually like fight in battle and
you know cause all sorts of raucous is
so the Stoics look at that they're like
none these are just allegories you know
don't believe in those fables they sure
they're great stories they express
something Universal about human nature
or the world but they're not really you
know truthful stories that are their
myths and legends that was person's
don't going to do so what we're going to
get in book 3 is this this guy kind of
his academic response and the academics
were like to find out Stefan's
when we say the word skeptic in our
culture what do we usually mean what do
we think of yeah people that what types
of questions things are like not only
them okay so questioning fresh name
assertions please tend not to believe
they want physical they want something
we want some sort of evidence some sort
of reason to believe I think you guys
have altered that that's saying about
you know Missouri being show me state
you know you got to show me I'm from
Missouri you know I'm not actually but
people set aside from Missouri you got
to show me you're going to demonstrate
to me go to give me a reason to believe
the claims you're making our actually
true so as a skeptic wats and skeptic
actually like I said before it comes
from the word meaning to seek the
skeptic koi were seekers and they
thought that you know there's a lot of
people out there with ideas and by this
time we had a couple different schools
of philosophy Plato school because old
schools
there's Aristotle school and there's the
Stoics that there's the Epicureans a few
other offshoots how do you know which of
these is actually right if any of them
are right well you have question you
have to go back to doing what it was
that Socrates did you got to go back to
that practice of dialectic and so one of
the things that the stoic are the
skeptics would actually do is one of
they would look at arguments of their
philosophical peers they would see if
they can find another argument to oppose
you say God cares about the world can we
find some arguments saying God doesn't
care about and if these arguments are
sort of balance themselves out and we
don't know you know think about this in
very ordinary terms think about your
decision to come here to marist did you
know it was going to be a good thing
first of all says it event a good thing
overall you guys coming tomorrow yeah
that's it is a very good place as far as
I can tell what I see I see a lot of
places I would send Mike it's here
matter of fact my daughter is actually
kind of interested in fashion
arrange for another two or something
sometime how did you know America will
the people okay so that there's no
that's a source of evidence right well
it's been in the papers it's like the
top eight yeah Maris makes it on these
lists a lot of like great places to go
for undergraduate education well in
front a lot of opportunities for all the
potential majors yeah soleado you
actually look at the literature and you
see like the study abroad program the
great program here Maris is really good
with hooking you guys up with
internships they do a lot of really
smart stuff yeah should I say Salta
campus okay that helps to it is a pretty
campus and some of the places you know
that you could go to you would actually
give you you'd be better just to like
learn about it in existence because if
you looked at it you might actually say
I don't want to put some some campuses
are ugly right Maris is the opposite you
did you know somebody well those are
that's enough stuff so so that's
evidence for you right now let's say
you've had some friends and say great
place think you'd really like it there
there's your crow that's right if you're
a skeptic you would want to see is there
anything on the con side that would
balance that up could you find anybody
who would say no I went there and waffle
or I sent my kids there and they had a
terrible time maybe you could write and
if you were a skeptic you would want to
try to find that can cover that I don't
know how you could compose the you know
being in this this top list thing maybe
you try to dig up some dirt you know
yeah is too
Mary's lack of holidays lack of hospital
kiss yeah I mean if you're balancing out
things that would probably be fairly
small small potatoes but you know hazel
compared to like it up yeah compare like
a good study abroad program or you know
like let's say you look at these things
the internships the study abroad program
maybe a dig ain't it maybe not everybody
goes on the study abroad program that
actually has the kind of experience that
they want you'd only know that if you
actually went and dug into it looked if
you go just by circus appearances or you
go up like somebody giving you some say
so I you might get fool I think all of
you have that experience at one time or
another not necessarily with Maris but
with with other things in your life were
you committed to something and
afterwards you realize you haven't
researched it well enough because it
didn't measure up to what you what you
thought it was going to be a skeptic
would say well you know that's often
when he happens try to find other ways
of looking at things that could counter
balance what you've got because if you
only look at the arguments for something
you're going to be convinced right
people often do this when they want to
be if it's the only look at one side and
everything looks great and they go ahead
and do people get into marriages this
way people get into business
arrangements this way people declare
their majors this way and then sometimes
sometimes that you're not happy ins at
times they don't the skeptic says you
should actually like hold yourself back
they advocate what they call suspension
really
and they had a special Greek word where
I let you know if you want to know
that's that's great i'm not gonna
require you to know this this great word
because we're not speaking Greek these
days it's called up okay which literally
means to hold one stuff back Enzo Pemex
of technical uses later on if you're
going to go further in philosophy so
that's what cod is about but you notice
there's another part but it goes about
it philosopher kata is also a practicing
Roman priests he carries out sacrifices
and kind of says something really
interesting this is where we get you
what we call the issue feedings in
matters of religion this comes from the
word for faith feed it that you don't
worry you've heard people say sometimes
when you ask them about something in
religion maybe maybe you're ready to
know some religious instruction classes
and some of the things that people were
saying to you sound a little bit hinky
or you know unbelievable and you're like
what's your evidence for that and they
say you just got it faith I can't
provide you just have to have faith this
is the kind of thing where you have to
make a commitment and that's all you can
do that would be a fee da istic point of
view and why would why would you
advocate that sort of thing well because
your view about a reason would be that
reason can't actually resolve all the
things we need to do and you might say
is that Miss Campbell with being a
skeptic skeptics are supposed to be all
about holy mediums bathroom things not
like launching yourself into some
unreasoned faith commitment well you
know think about why kata because
how is afia's in matters of religion he
actually says all these arguments for
God's existence the only argument you
really need is that re ancestors said
this was so the argument from tradition
that should strike is a pretty weak
article should know Thomas Aquinas
actually said that is the weakest of all
arguments for God's existence the fact
that some people before us and that's
the way it is because I mean think about
your parents grandparents are they right
all the time you're at the age of you
starting to realize you're right about a
lot of things you thought they were
totally wrong about teenagers right but
even even when you get to the point
where like tan mom and dad actually did
know quite a bit of stuff you're still
not going to think they were infallible
and I don't think about people before us
there's all sorts of crazy things I used
to believe I'll give you one example in
my grandparents generation so you know
age there are generations are a little
bit wider or longer than yours so this
would be like your great grandparents
generation or great-great grandparents
generation when they would get a cold or
a cough you know their home remedy was
Andy what's up that'd be good if they
would have done that because that's not
actually harmful to you they would
gargle kerosene they didn't drink and
thank God well you know they didn't know
they could that kerosene is carcinogenic
and it's not good for you people did
stuff like that when I was a kid and we
would go on painting jobs you don't used
to wash our hands with me yes that's not
good for you either cuz up but you know
my uncle didn't he said here do that so
you know I figured he knew best the
argument from tradition is not a very
good argument because you know you never
know if these people are actually struck
piccata says guessing on the argument
that I
by in part because he is a Roman priest
he is somebody who he has to deal with
this this problem you can't actually is
Israel you can't actually wait around
for complete evidence to be supplied at
any sort of philosophical manner in
matters of religion why not because you
got a deal with them down especially if
you actually have a job this big
religious authority that he probably
inherited quite frankly so there's a
distinction here that's being made as a
philosopher he can't say one way or the
other and he actually talks about who
was it oh there's another day Oh Simona
days there was a Greek compelling some
other days it's offered he was a really
smart guy he gets offered some some
money or a prize by this guy hero
because he rose interested in knowing
about the gods so he says hey Simona
days tell me about these guys and some
already says okay I'll take on your job
I'll take out that Commission and so the
heroes comes from the next day says you
know I need two more days just give me
two more days and all I would figure it
out and then hero comes to him the next
day or two days later and he says you
know I don't think 18 four days there's
give me four days I'll have to figure it
out you see what this is going right
doubling at each time he'll never arrive
in an answer Willie and you know why
because if you're an academic when it
comes to these sort of really murky
matters about religion I have linked
event has been funny confused about
religion and religious leaves and why
all these people have these different
notions during your life right it's kind
of confusing and then when people say
things like you know god is love what
does that mean you know I mean that
every time right long somebody's a
little bit of God there there's a lot of
confusing stuff Connor would say yeah
you're trying to look at this just by
using human reason just by using the
resources that we possess on our own
you're not going to actually arrive at a
good answer these other people out there
with the Stoics and the Epicurean
they've revived with the answers but
they're just making stuff up there
buying into things without having good
evidence on the other hand as a
practitioner as somebody who has some
sort of Revelation or tradition to rely
upon then it can be dealt with as a
matter of faith irrational commitments
fede istic Sony's kind of split
personalities but this is cuz this is
possible for a stoic you can say yeah as
a philosopher here's what I think don't
really know anything as a theologian as
somebody who's talking about the guides
on the basis of the gods have given me
some inside track some inside
information I can actually be certain
about this stuff that's his position so
when it comes to the other artists bless
you for God's existence and the things
that the stoics are saying he's going to
be very critical so let's look at look
at those things down do you remember
what those five arguments were want p.m.
for God's existence that we looked at
last time that all this had made yeah
horn honking center okay consent
miracles don't see it now oh yeah you
guys personally when you run through
these putting aside your own religious
beliefs whatever they happen to be
looking at this sort of stuff you can
philosophical are there any of these
that you would actually find plausible
or even convince them yeah with anyone
else by design good hows it aside from
the airport understand yeah medical what
about them is a name is hitting these
other ones yeah so that you find that
that it's a lot of people are not a lot
of people just about everybody leave
something probably a vertical probably
strip the gym to be Austin yeah hello
okay yo that's a sort of kind of deep
metaphysical argument there did they
move find the degrees first of all did
anyone actually understand the degrees
of being are you know kinda hippie is
it's one that's hard to wrap your head
around so some of these are at least
plausible to you aside from whether you
actually his daughter not even if you
didn't believe in God maybe some of
these would be convincing I think these
days the world like its appeal to the
most is probably designed in our
contemporary
and miracles tends to be something
that's preaching to the choir or in a
lot of cases common consensus harder to
do these days because we do have a lot
of 80s up right and so you can't say
everybody everybody believes you don't
see too many people doing the
intelligence one although that one would
be an interesting one to try out now
kind of says all these fails there's
something wrong with always in the text
that we have there are some gaps the
manuscripts that we have or some of
these ancient texts are complete so we
don't actually have a sore like I'm
going to now attack the argument from
degrees and being here's my my counter
heart event portion but we do have
something I'm kind of address but all
the rest of these he actually comes out
he says this one doesn't work he was why
this one doesn't work here's why this
one doesn't work here's why let's go
through these then we'll think about why
Cicero's doing this so against the
argument from common consent we talked
about some of the problems with this
before right just because every single
culture has some sort of general belief
in something doesn't necessarily mean
that it's true I mean there are things
that ancient cultures sort of
universally believed in that we don't
think actually are on track here's
here's an example him to do with social
relations every ancient society once it
developed past a certain point pen
slavery at the institution of slavery
and that's that sort of the factual
judgment and every ancient culture that
had slavery had a lot of people in that
society who said slavery is something
that's natural to the human condition
and I want to be there now you know in
recent times we've changed that that's
pretty recent and we still actually do
this
some parts of the walk going slavery
some certain forms even here in the
United States criminal still goes on now
we wouldn't want to say just because
every ancient culture thought that
slavery there was some sort of good
basis to it maybe not everybody who's a
slave ought to be a slave but some
people at least obviously we won want to
say the bastard would we just because
all these you know the ancient Chinese
ancient Mayans ancient Greeks they all
believed in this so maybe we wouldn't
want to say that about about the gods to
the other thing that he says which is
kind of a funny remark when it comes to
matters of important manners do you feel
I on just anybody now let's think about
a couple different important matters
would you would you take just anybody's
ideas about what you got to do with your
money no why not well 1e if you're not
an accountant and are an expert on the
money manager or something ready I'm not
going to take your guys do you don't
know my situation look at my tendencies
I mean you've a suggestion but that's
about as far as I can go try to most
Americans right now how are most
Americans doing when it comes to man
not too good we have a negative savings
rate and we've had it for a long time
and yeah I mean we're going deeper and
deeper in debt it's not just the country
its individual households and there's
all sorts of reasons for this you know I
mean we can get into that's all the trim
time subject matter of fact a colleague
of mine [ __ ] a intro to philosophy class
that was just focused on that he kind of
cool concept to do was enough we're not
we're just using it as an example here
what about some musical taste do you
only buy the things that are the most
popular because everybody likes them no
so the ordinary person where the
aggregate of ordinary people is not a
good judge of musical taste no what
about what's most popular food you think
it's okay so I really like being so one
with the most popular pizza chain is
very downloads
Jones that's how he said yeah see now
notice what we're doing here right kada
actually says hey you and subjective
judgment to a bunch of fools would you
be called fools so the argument from
common consent is its appealing to the
masses and you know remember these guys
are all aristocratic Romans two so they
don't think the masses at all and maybe
there's maybe there's something wrong
bad attitude as well but he says you
know there's a counter argument that
let's go on to miracles what are some of
the problems with miracles we talked
about this is economies these samples
yeah things that are just beyond our
reasoning or logic seen like magically
miracles but when reality there's just
one little trick behind yeah actually
that's one thing that he comes out
explicit instance we didn't actually get
to that in previous classes but that's
that's a weak point that he he sort of
you know drives the night at him and he
does it in terms of this notion of
divination divination is we would often
translate as fortune-telling but it's
really trying to ascertain the will of
the gods so if you really believe that
the gods care about you that presumably
you can find out what they want to tell
you in some way you know like some
people do this by there's an old English
that opening up the Bible like and I was
picking a verse at random there's God
talking to you right maybe that works
there's a personal people I don't some
some cultures you know we talked about
this cast lots and I mean they look at
the results usually they in turn
some sort of book some sort of tradition
that they use and Conda had made this
argument we couldn't actually have
divination you couldn't have experts of
divination if you didn't have divination
and what does divination divination is
like finding out what the gods want
couldn't have that if there weren't any
God so therefore there must be guys and
Cano says tell me exactly how this works
now I understand our medicine works and
that's a rational part and doctors if
you go to them they can actually give
you a rational explanation for why
they're prescribing this course of
treatment and not that course of
treatment and you know some sort of our
doctors here today to do that some of
them tell right you're the doctor and
sometimes it shut up and take this and
that's not getting a rational
explanation but sometimes they'll
actually know especially you're paying
them good money they will give you big
decent explanation well I want you to
take this because your your metabolism
is too slow or you've got you know this
this bacteria that the test showed up
and we want to kill it or who knows
something that's right it's divination a
rational part like that it seems kind of
made up as you go along doesn't so
that's not that's not a rational
explanation then and we can say the same
thing about miracles just because it
seems really surprising you know these
examples of lightning and all that just
because if we don't have an explanation
for it doesn't get being that we should
say there's some god they're doing that
what about design design is kind of
interested to and again this is one that
people have found pretty convincing
through the years he's got three main
lines of attack on us he says well you
know this goes to the rational
explanation we don't have to necessarily
assume some some intelligent designer
out there couldn't there be some natural
rational explanation
for for all the phenomena that we see
like you know think about the the design
well let's not take the eigen hundred
Darwin so that's that's a tough one for
me why do we walk up can we think of it
good sort of gap we're not happening to
all evolutionary biologist but can we
think of a good reason why it could be
to our advantage to walk around like
this yeah um well according to a natural
selection the reason why we do is
because the people or the place animals
or species before us that had more of an
upright stance survived or that are able
to survive it to seem like yeah because
you can actually see things right and
you can it frees up your hands so you
can like make tools and throw Spears and
shoot arrows or is it as over your
insight here already inside I was going
to say that our heads are happy oh yeah
we also have this that's a whole
different thing we've got this massive
drink that's part of why we have to have
child rearing because it takes a long
time for our brains to develop and birth
is difficult for for human beings in
part because we have these massive
noggins compared to other other animals
you know we have this giant wetware
computer rain well I mean do you have to
postulate a God in order to explain that
sort of thing not necessarily you could
you could come up you could come up with
other explanations and if you can come
up with other explanations then the
argument from design should should we
mr. Scott I'm not sure I'm hundred
percent correct but Christianity believe
that we are making the image yes and
that's an interesting idea there have
been all sorts of discussions on what it
what exactly does that mean actually but
in the Book of Wisdom against it gets
even more remain not only in the image
of God but after the energy I cotto
taste God and so people like st. Thomas
for example will say how are we in made
in the image of guys I think God has
like thinkers and stuff like that no
it's we're rational that's how we're
similar to God take heart organs study
later on says we're like God more in our
will or will a rationality is kind of
kind of weak that's not very much like
gods and but our will is unbounded and
that's like God there's a lot of
different explanations clement of
alexandria says that we are like God in
that we are musical which is kind of an
interesting thing to think about it's
got this beautiful beautiful natural not
again we're reading this glasses he's
tough time may be tougher than the
people you're reading now let's let's go
on with this so the other the other
problem that comes off is there really
an analogy let's think about what design
arguments actually worked with theirs
it's sort of like when we talk about
analogy you guys remember when you're
taking sats and we said dog is to hobby
as a diff to bird mouse calf kitten
which is it yeah the answer d and yeah
right that that's an analogy so in this
case the analogy is there suffered and
some sort of part of that then we say
look you know anything that we we have
you know in our experience take this for
example do this stuff all sort of come
together by chance on its own or through
an evolutionary process it doesn't work
like that right look at all this why is
this here so it can close up right
there's there's a purpose to the design
why why does it have this strap so
somebody can cure it there's all sorts
of features that this thing has why it
made out of straw why did they make out
of leather instead so I can last so I
can put a computer in so people like me
are very tough on things don't destroy
so there's a design that artifact all
right this is the design features built
into even this does all these cheap
marys cups you can get at the store and
then refill your coffee or an over yet
there's there's reasons why things are
the way they are right this is a good
way to make a handle so you can actually
like hold it for it what about the
actual things aren't they pretty complex
don't they have a lot of functions well
there must be some sort of designer God
for them to write
does the analogy really hold them is is
they're the kind of intentional you know
functional clear design to natural
things and where there is for artifacts
let me know it's kind of hard to tell I
mean didn't according to the design
theory somebody actually said yeah
that's virus we're going to make this
work out this way so this protein shell
can go into blood streams and catch on
the cells and then inject this little
little snippet of code and take over the
cell and like it will make it make a
whole bunch of new viruses the first I
don't know how somebody could have
designed that right we monkey around
flyer says but if that's God God's kind
of jerk right then you could come up
with a you know well grand purpose web
of life kind of kind of explanations but
that's not very that's not very
consoling from somebody who's getting
sick is the virus but you know the virus
does is the design that really like the
design of this is there a strong analogy
there rosette is that kind of week
that's that's what he ends up saying the
argument of intelligence which again is
one that I actually like quite a death
he makes a number of criticisms against
the argument from intelligence and
remember where did the Stoics say that
his intelligence came from came from god
but God is the world right so that makes
a little bit vulnerable it's not like
you know Jewish Christian most
consumption God is being outside of the
world or where you could say you know
you can't just like point to it and say
AHA that doesn't look at rational
because you can't see here
smell ya right but you can look at the
world less the world as a whole does
that look awfully rational to you the
world as a whole the universe is the
University to be thinking arranging
itself deliberately aware of you maybe
you know maybe much less in modern times
we need to think of ourselves as being a
cold universe and wherever just this
tiny little planet and we're tiny little
things in this tiny little planet you
know you realize that the bulk of our
planet is not were experiencing we're
just living on the thin thin crust of
that over a big ball of nickel and
higher all right that's can spinning
around in the hot inside we're pretty
small potatoes thanks but you know we're
different in that will ration does a
universe of self rational we don't see
any signs of that we made you know we'll
say we fight some aliens we'd say yeah
now we found some intelligent life right
according to the stoics we should say we
found intelligent life already it's just
the whole universe but we don't we don't
say things like that do we she says the
very notion of rationality being in the
world is kind of confusing things Stoics
didn't really make good sense out of
that again maybe not some so much of a
big problem for you know Jewish
Christian Muslim conceptions of God's
being transcendent to
universe but it's a definite problem for
the stoic conception of God is being the
universe so you stoics have to actually
explain what this means the other thing
that's going to be really interesting
we're going to get to visit MIT is read
what is reason or rationality always a
good thing the Stoics are assuming that
it is that's where they're you know
being able to say you know you can't get
something better from something worse
you can't get something higher from
something lower maybe rationality is not
always the best thing finally the
argument from degrees of being like I
said there's no explicit place where
he's addressing this we lost that
portion of the text it looks like but
one possible line of criticism would be
if the world is supposed to be entirely
rational which is what you know all this
is saying then we should also expect it
to be doing a lot of other things that
human beings can do to like you know
we're going up the degrees of being and
each degree like add something to it it
doesn't take something away what are
some of the things that you guys do
distinctively human Thanks the army
animals have emotions but we have we
have some some particular as a given so
let's let's do that animals get angry
there's pull a dog's tail in terms of
our bikes you could say in gray right
but animals don't feel righteous
indignation in the universe or God in
all this is highest degree of the angel
in the universe feel righteous
indignation against somebody aside from
cartoons or the volcano gets mad or
things like that Scooby Doo I don't
think so what other distinctive you
thanks we do well remember the stomachs
are saying the universe is intelligent
so that's not a prompt assistance fools
what's up yeah I suppose yeah the
universe universe should be using tools
in that respect the universe doesn't
have it tools all it has is yet
universit laughs yeah the universe
should read books because we read books
maybe write books to see how he's being
kind of silly pleases the universe
itself should be musical and compose
songs because that's something human
beings do you know for each higher
degree of being as they added something
to it if you want to buy into this this
notion of higher degrees of being with
whatever is in the top it better be the
thing that like does everything it's not
just you know living and sentient
rational it's also musical it's also
literate it's also got a good sense of
humor the best sense of humor because
it's at the top right yeah we do their
video
yeah well it would be a problem for the
degrees of being marketed to them I mean
you can get around that by saying that
that what we're doing is in some ways
transforming what they do on a lower
level like what would be something that
the animals do that we don't
will they have to hit their own food we
had it so so are we I mean we just pay
for it well in a way it's mass-produced
you know we need to grocery store
instead of having actually punch board
that's an interesting idea that sort of
saying that technology transforms us
into something radically different than
our animal condition interesting thought
to work out let me go let me go back to
this now so let's look at this issue of
rationality itself I'm going to skip
over the discussion of whether the
guides are good or just or anything like
that because we'll hit that at the very
end of this rationalization so let's
think about these that that's important
thing for the design argument that's
important thinker intelligence already
know the degrees of being the stoics
think that God is is where the guys are
totally rational and one way that you
can tell that the gods actually like us
is the gods or God you know I've known
to possess pull the rational and God's
care of us
giving us reason is that meeting years
that does take us beyond the level vm so
actually that's a good good place where
that notion about you know we don't have
to all go out and hunt our own food
comes in the animals for the most part I
know you know like mommy Tigers you know
feed their young and stuff with that but
after a while the Tigers gotta fend for
themselves right Jeezy that has to get
its own food and yeah there's some hands
that you know use Athens to make honey
and bees do some weird stuff too but for
the most part the animals have to feed
themselves we're able to use our faculty
of reason to think things out so 99% of
us don't have to make our own food other
than like popping in the microwave we're
cooking on the stove right I don't know
I made three dishes yesterday I made
chicken salad and meatloaf and speak
meatballs and pasta sauce none of which
we actually had for dinner your officer
stocking up for for the rest of the week
of the weekends my way to work a lot
right so those are things that keep
eventually amateurs four four dishes
last night I didn't talk that cow three
of those dishes actually have ground
beef oh they all came from the same
package of ground beef that's somebody
ground up and put it there and we got it
Sam's Club and Sam's bumped into God get
the cow there's like a whole chain right
that's all the examples of reason reason
lets us do some incredible spots but is
rationality necessarily a good thing
case cada brings up some examples where
it's not yeah and he says let's look at
a few cases and he brings up mythical
Legendary's connect this to your own
time think about movies they think about
songs especially love songs with
something goes bad and somebody is going
to take care of it that way especially
folks folks ons are full open up love
triangles that end up with somebody
getting killed in the Greek stories in
the greed plays it's pretty horrific
things happen and they're done by people
to other people and those people planned
it out and thought how am I going to do
this and how am I going to get away with
Medea is the example that he is Medea is
the one who helped Jason get the Golden
Fleece she actually turned out her own
people love for him to help him ouch she
went with him to to Greece now she's
sort of like you know a traitor to her
own people has a couple kids with Jason
and then Jason who's always kind of
schmuck Jason starts like cozying up to
the daughter of the king because he
wants to marry her and like establish
himself there and the day is like this
is not going to be good for me or my
kids and she's really really angry she
tries to talk about he won't do it so
you know she does she's gonna fix him
she's really angry
yeah she she kills she gives a gift of
some sort of like a crown yeah how much
light filled with poison like the kids
bring it in I just had to read it
Euripides yeah did you order Serena too
yeah it doesn't he like kind of person
yes later on yes and she does a ton of
damage she kills her kids who she loves
but she's like hey you know if I was
gonna be bad for you and if you know
something about ancient Greek culture
she her kids really would have been on
their own after after he takes another
wife and she so she destroys Jason's
life destroys their progeny and then
flies off in a chariot drawn by dragons
so she's actually thought about an
escape plan she's actually got an exit
strategy it's rationality that's
reasoning she actually thought through
all these things in the player actually
reasons about this stuff she says well
if this than this that's reasoning in
comedies people do all sorts of bad
things to minor pad things and
oftentimes they explain why it is to
their advantage to do them or they
convince each other hey yeah and you
ought to do this it's usually about
things like stealing something or
cheating on somebody not try not to work
we should do she do a party today
instead of going to work think about all
sorts of you know teen comedies right
there's all sorts of reasoning going
down there not good reasoning no reason
in ordinary life never see people come
to the wrong conclusion wrong morally in
reasoning maybe you've done it yourself
I know I have plenty of times you know I
have done some dumb stuff in my lifetime
using reason you know think what would
happen if I did this I should try it out
I remember when I was a kid I stuck my
mom's car keys and went back down there
thin enough I stopped her car keys into
the electrical socket blew out the
attack me you know back I was like four
years old I remember everything turning
blue you know her for a minute and this
terrible pain and the key like hell to
the bed yeah it was a big mess but you
know what you later yeah I didn't do
that again you know it all you know
there are kids animal to do that dogs
don't do that castle monkeys will do
that because monkeys are a lot like us
they're kind of curious there's that
rationale via legal cases if you ever go
to sit in on my court people make
arguments on both sides and somebody
will say yeah I should have I should
have done this thing on the other
personal be like no you shouldn't have
done that thing and there are there
saying I should have done it because
because that's that's reality and he
says actually not only do a lot of bad
things seem to involve reason like you
know crimes you can't actually do them
without reasoning so this is kind of an
indignant of reason reason can be used
for bad purposes are at us Anna can
result in bad choices and actions if you
don't we can use it for a lot of good
things too but but it's you know it's
kind of half and half maybe you could
actually use
to analyze your own reasoning to figure
out whether it's bad reasoning or not
but here's where we get to another
interesting point the most people do
that no most people use reason not as
some sort of governing faculty this is
this cop that you know keeps them on the
right path and leaves them two together
better things and doesn't need something
virtues and not transgressing people's
rights most people use reason just when
they have to and then to give what it is
that they want so it's not just
possessing reason it's a question of
whether you possess right and that
everybody has this so rationality by
itself is not necessarily a good thing
so let's go back to this where the gods
really taken care of us by giving us
this loaded gun that has like an
unlimited animal which you know we can
all turn out each other or ourselves in
a moment's notice you know reason is
what makes us the most dangerous animals
human beings can figure out all sorts of
ways to kill or maim or cheat or deceive
each other than animals just can't do
our rationality is what makes us the
most dangerous and difficult you know if
you think of paranoia paranoia is like
reason in a certain sense
on man God why just thinking all the
time somebody's out to get you yes it
who is it it's him Alistair thinking
about ya noticed I'm doing this thing to
you and what should I do if he's got to
get me there can him first there's a guy
who you're not going to read this
semester thomas hobbes who talks about
precisely this sort of thing why human
beings are so dangerous to each other so
to the gods do the right thing no you
know you could get the gods off the hook
made these by saying it's not their
fault you know person misuse reason
right they give everybody a nice gift
and some people think about it in terms
of money right let's say I suddenly gave
I also had a ton of money and I'm
Spencer like it up it was all been one
big test right everybody who's been
showing up regularly gets 20 million
bucks hi yourself away right so I give
everybody 12 20 million bucks out of my
infinite resources how many of you would
screw it up you would well it's good you
know somebody will admit most people if
you give them a ton of money it's not
actually doing them a big favor you
actually have to have the right
dispositions of place soft control or
else that that great amount of money
might actually turn out to be a bad
thing for you now the gods are there
giving a good thing right is it is if
their fault than people misuse it sounds
plausible but then you could say if you
guys should know better aren't you
supposed to be totally rational aren't
you supposed to be able to like think
ahead so if you give for example you
know none of you are crack addicts
because otherwise you wouldn't be here
at marys because if you're a crack
addict pretty much your life is dust you
know that way with crack heroin and meth
and
some of the other hard drugs as well you
really cannot do much in and be pursuing
that lifestyle at the same time is it a
good thing to give a crack addict 20
blocks even if you tell them hey don't
want you to use this for drugs what's
going to help ya they'll take the money
and they'll say yes yeah I'm gonna use
it to 25 I'm going to use it to
straighten myself out and I'm going to
buy myself some good meal and give it
two hundred bucks I'm going to get a
suit time go to job interviews this part
of my life is over then the next day all
the money's going in there and they're
high now if you actually are totally
rational you want to be able to see that
coming right so if you're giving
rationality to people who are not
completely good can't you see that
that's likely to be bad so this is again
we come to this issue of The Odyssey
kada thinks that the gods if they
actually did give us rationality they
probably screwed up they're doing
something and if it's up to somebody
else who wants to say that God did the
right thing to explain God's ways to
give it a theodicy yeah organization
when you go to your buddy and
this house all like you know you see a
couple of drunk people being funnier
yeah for my instance in the Marine Corps
you know you still there somebody for
instance when you look at your body like
this idiot you know you know something
bad could happen but you sit back and
watch oh yeah so the guys are like that
you're saying they're there they're
doling out these these these powers to
people on there saying yeah this is
gonna be this going to be a good show
right yeah but isn't kyle using like
parenting we're together so you have the
kids know you give up what you tell them
to do certain things at the end of the
day just kind of like their decision
ultimately do what they want yeah and
you know their condom doesn't make this
argument and Balbus doesn't make this
argument yes but there could be an
argument that we had to be given
rationality that wasn't fully developed
so that we could in fact develop it for
Augustine was going to make an argument
kind of like that look at what he has to
say yeah well one thing that being
arguing for like the gods like or giving
us like a for thing is even in the Greek
goddess Pandora's box well that wasn't a
nice thing oh what's that wasn't them
helping out that was that was like that
screwing over do but that's what I'm
Tony like sometimes their gifts like the
if I remember legend right with Zeus he
gave the app contains all the eagle
to end or so she would say keep it and
she goes and opens and unleashes all
living hell on earth yeah now that works
for the ancient Greek gods remember the
Stoics of rejected them the Stoics think
that god is good god is prominent God
takes care of all created PX and so it
wouldn't work with it God wouldn't give
you something like shine jewelers box
but this is how I guess is what we're
calling reasoning well that's what
that's what Coty's things yeah reasoning
turns out to be kind of a Pandora's box
you Stoics actually you didn't think
this through all the way because look at
all these things in half and kind of
concludes either God is ignorant of his
powers that doesn't seem to work right
or God is indifferent to human affairs
the stoics don't want to accept that
your God is unable to judge what's best
and that would be that God isn't fully
rational so he's setting up a dilemma
yeah I'll maybe we could be like
compensation for lack of like resources
for all like that it has to get checked
online population ya sayin like that's
why people kill each other along in it
they don't then we'll die of starvation
or something like that so maybe it's
just like compensation for show the
benefits of species as a whole and I'm
now going to be concerned the species
but not at the individual yeah not the
poor Schmucks who actually are in the
wrong place at the wrong time and end up
being being the ones who have to
yeah I mean you know the stoics we're
willing to give up on the notion of
God's being concerned for individual
human beings that will be an out for
them so this is really presenting a big
challenge to the stars now if it's one
that you can meet you guys are
suggesting some interesting lines
Augustine who are going to look at next
a couple class sessions he's going to
try to deal with this problem of
theodicy as well Jewish and Christian
and Muslim thinkers have brought out
some stronger arguments in favor of God
was actually doing the right thing God
was on the ball even though there is
evil even though you know people do do
the wrong things and they'll do it by
relocating the responsibility for the
wrong where do you think what's up wait
the reasons it won't see it won't be
actually the gods responsibility yeah
it'll be the individual agent individual
person some people would be tough to say
that's deaf as well but you know
traditional Orthodox Judaism
Christianity Muslims stuff doesn't
doesn't just write it everything off by
saying well somebody else's fault yeah
well I'm just going to kind of say that
a good argument would be since we are
considering the animals are we are
available yeah is there still the
survival that they even though we know
we keeper hold the light for an extra
thing I think of a good what what you
were talking about to right right it
could be better for the human race done
hold at the weaker parish that's all
again the guys would be concerned not
for not for individuals but for the
species as a whole that would be a
possibility and there would be a big
difference between being Providence in
terms of the human race and then being
prominent
but again the Stoics are committed Ian
really anybody else who's talking about
God they all end up being competitive
God cares about individuals and not just
like the individuals we happen to make
it it's not a mommy dearest God or
something like that it's a it's a god or
death race god it's a champions are
worthy of my love you know that kind of
thing it's a guy who supposedly cares
about all this is a real metaphysical
problem this is what we call the problem
of evil and in modern times this has
been used to argue that there is no god
but uses an argument against the
existence of God in ancient times it
really wasn't used as an argument
against the existence of God because
they some of them are willing to say
yeah I'll kick God doesn't care our God
only cares about the species but not the
individuals they have the curious right
gods are happy why because they don't
care because they're not interested the
stoics couldn't say that the academics
notice the academics don't really know
he's made all these arguments this is
the last thing i want to say he's made
all these arguments kada doesn't say I
had a definitive position of it I just
don't think the other people who got
neuritis what is safe where does since
i'll be block cicero remembers in
academic so he should be lined up with
collar what is the very last line tell
us he's actually attractive to the stoic
position I remember the stars are saying
yeah I think we've got some definite
things we can say about God
ads it doesn't say he's 100 years have
committed dozen says and I found
Wallace's arguments the stronger what is
the epicurean this is kind of
interesting to tonight's he actually
says yeah maybe I'm wrong about this
maybe cottam actually this right these
academics are all right so the epicurean
himself is not that convinced of his own
position by the end of this people
change their minds through philosophical
argument that's part of why I have you
guys read this because people actually
do read this stuff and they think about
it and then sometimes they change the
point of view